ogni bella storia inizia con un mostro
da sconfiggere un problema da risolvere
e io ho capito qual era la mia passione
nel momento in cui ho capito qual era il
problema che doveva affrontare
vedete è un problema che non coinvolge
solo me coinvolge tutti noi e per
raccontarvelo prima voglio coinvolgervi
in un gioco un piccolo quiz quattro
domande molto veloce
dovete semplicemente rispondere alle
domande e tenere a mente quante risposte
corrette riuscite a dare la prima è dei
soldi È più sicuro investirli in un solo
business Oppure in diversi business
la risposta è diversi business
il concetto che c'è dietro alla
diversificazione sembra un concetto
tecnico no difficile da capire in realtà
si tratta soltanto di capire come
ottenere gli stessi risultati ma
sobbarcandosi meno rischi
nei prossimi 10 anni I prezzi
raddoppiano se ricevessi una paga doppia
riusciresti a comprare meno di quanto
compri oggi quanto compri oggi o più di
quanto compri oggi
la risposta è quanto compri oggi
il concetto dell'aumento dei prezzi è
l'inflazione magari la conoscete
Ultimamente sta tornando in Auge si
sente anche nei giornali non si vedeva
da tantissimi anni e ora invece dobbiamo
tornare a fare i conti con l'inflazione
la terza domanda
ti prestano 100 euro quale sarebbe la
somma minore da restituire 105 euro o
100 euro più il 3%,
la risposta corretta è 100 euro più il
3%,
sembra un problema soltanto di Finanza o
di matematica le percentuali Beh in
questo caso stiamo parlando di interesse
il costo del denaro nel tempo
Però magari questo discorso delle
percentuali serve anche un po' a capire
cose un po' più di tutti i giorni quando
andiamo a comprare dei vestiti e ci sono
i saldi e non sappiamo calcolare bene il
prezzo dei saldi degli sconti l'ultima
domanda ai 100 euro in banca La banca
ogni anno aggiunge il 10% al tuo
deposito al tuo conto Senza prelevare
dopo 5 anni nel conto avresti più di 150
euro esattamente 150 euro o meno di 150
euro
la risposta è più di 150 euro questo è
meno conosciuto il concetto
dell'interesse composto la possibilità
di guadagnare dai guadagni che abbiamo
già fatto in passato reinvestendoli
ora perché vi ho fatto queste domande
Intanto voglio sapere per alzata di mano
Quanti di voi hanno trovato più di tre
risposte corrette
Beh un pubblico fantastico queste
quattro domande sono state fatte non
soltanto in Italia ma in tutto il mondo
e hanno tirato fuori quello che era il
problema Il nostro mostro quello che
vogliamo sconfiggere
siamo gli ultimi in educazione
finanziaria Il mostro è l'analfabetismo
finanziario
Questo è quello che facciamo cerchiamo
di fare informazione il 33% di adulti
nel mondo in media hanno le competenze
minime per fare delle scelte finanziarie
quindi le conoscenze di base in Italia
siamo messi leggermente meglio ma
comunque è un problema ma solo il 37%,
ha queste competenze di base
questo problema non è soltanto per gli
adulti Noi siamo più interessati al
futuro siamo più interessati a giovani e
sui giovani sono stati Condotti dei test
le prove Pisa questi sono i risultati
della Financial literacy Condotti nel
2015 poi di nuovo nel 2018 ma risultati
sono abbastanza simili se non peggiori e
l'Italia è qui sotto la media dei paesi
più sviluppati
continua a esserci un problema di
analfabetismo finanziario che coinvolge
sia i grandi che piccoli piccoli da me
in giù
perché perché abbiamo questo problema
uno si potrebbe chiedere ma abbiamo
problemi di matematica non capiamo bene
i discorsi abbiamo problemi di lettura
invece no
qua ci dicono che siamo All'ultimo posto
di questa di questa piccola classifica
perché a parità di punteggi totalizzati
su matematica e lettura In realtà noi
andiamo peggio sulla analfabetismo
finanziario
Allora siamo è un problema di ricchezza
Beh di solito c'è una relazione tra la
ricchezza di un paese il pro capite e
l'educazione finanziaria
anche qui siamo sotto la media
cosa ci manca è la domanda necessaria da
porsi
Beh quando abbiamo iniziato a lavorare a
questi concetti
abbiamo capito che non avevamo gli unici
a occuparsene ci sono istituzioni
autorità tante persone diverse ma la
risposta che mi sento di dare e che
mancano le storie
mancano delle storie che ci ispirino
Pensate ai viaggi intergalattici che
ispirano le prossime generazioni di
Astronauti e di ingegneri aerospaziali
gli strumenti ci mancano le ore passate
da bambini al computer che poi magari
possono portare a diventare
programmatori
Beh a noi manca Questo manca una cultura
finanziaria manca qualcosa a cui
ispirarci
Io porto questa maglietta nel lavoro che
faccio e richiama uno dei pochi film che
parlano di Finanza e richiama le crisi
sempre qualcosa Un po' controverso un
po' negativo
In realtà io sono davvero contento di
essere stato invitato qui perché
mi aspettavo questo invito me lo sarei
aspettato tra qualche anno magari e tra
qualche anno avrei potuto finalmente
sfoggiare Edoardo Scirè tedesco speaker
Beh è una roba No Fa un bell'effetto Io
faccio parte del mondo delle startup
Le startup si fregiano di tanti titoli
c'è chi è Sio c'è chi è founder
cofounder Bravo under 13 Ecco io non
sono niente di tutto ciò non sono
neanche più underderti
ma ho avuto la fortuna di conoscere
questi due ragazzi qui dietro Edoardo Di
Lella e Marco scioli dei ragazzi
motivati fortissimi e con loro abbiamo
capito che avevamo degli interessi in
comune avevamo la necessità di parlare
di tematiche di Economia e di Finanza
e non solo tra di noi non solo tra i
nostri amici ma anche agli altri
il mio ruolo è quello di Cif content
officer che ha un nome altisonante è un
titolo un po' così un content Creator
con le mani di grandezza adesso cosa
vuol dire vuol dire che io insieme a
tantissime altre persone molto brave
costruiscono delle storie e le racconto
su diversi Social su YouTube su
Instagram Facebook Tik Tok Cioè senza
fare pubblicità a tutti quanti
noi cerchiamo di costruire un linguaggio
nuovo Ma da dove partiamo partiamo dal
fatto che l'elemento fondamentale è
costruire una community
una comunità di persone che hanno gli
stessi interessi che parlano lo stesso
linguaggio e che hanno degli obiettivi
simili è lo strumento fondamentale per
far avvicinare gli altri e magari anche
voi un giorno potrete far parte della
nostra community
vedete
quando si parla di interessi o
linguaggio e obiettivo si parla della
nostra storia perché quando abbiamo
iniziato a occuparci di questi temi in
realtà non è che stavo pensando alla
analfabetismo finanziario erano i nostri
interessi era ciò che ci accomunava di
più
c'era Chi era studente chi voleva
lavorare in Finanza chi voleva fare gli
investimenti
e Beh ognuno aveva la sua passione
ma queste passioni erano simili abbiamo
iniziato a parlarne tra di noi abbiamo
iniziato a confrontarci A consigliarci
come approfondire E questo ci ha portato
piano piano a darci qualcosa abbia
iniziato a scrivere abbiamo iniziato ad
aprire un blog un sito dei canali Social
ovviamente soffre di divulgazione
tramite post iril il video lunghi di
tutto e di più
abbiamo capito
che dovevamo trovare un linguaggio
diverso
abbiamo capito che dovevamo imparare a
parlare il linguaggio dei nostri amici
non si può parlare di Economia e di
Finanza usando soltanto termini tecnici
non posso stare qui a parlarvi di
diversificazione di derivati mi devo
parlare di qualcos'altro usare immagini
diverse
ci scontriamo con questo problema io di
economia non ci capisco nulla Lo avrete
sentito dire milioni di volte nel
momento in cui avete iniziato a parlare
di impresa
ce l'hanno detto tutti i nostri amici è
il momento in cui tutti abbassano la
saracinesca non li recuperi più io di
economia non ci capisco nulla
bene
abbiamo continuato abbiamo insistito
abbiamo continuato a parlare con tutti e
questo ci ha dato modo di scoprire il
grande problema Il problema che abbiamo
visto all'inizio il mostro
analfabetismo finanziario È qualcosa che
colpisce l'Italia il mondo ma
soprattutto i nostri amici le persone di
cui ci vogliamo prendere cura i nostri
familiari e allora abbiamo trovato un
obiettivo un obiettivo che non era
conseguito soltanto da noi abbiamo detto
Ci sono tante autorità tante istituzioni
che se ne occupano che studiano modi per
fare piani educativi adesso arriverà
anche nelle scuole e sicuramente tutto
questo è importantissimo e utile
fondamentale
ma noi abbiamo detto non possono fare
tutto da soli c'è bisogno di un aiuto e
così abbiamo creato Starting Finance
Start in finanzam startup che si occupa
di divulgazione sia online che dal vivo
non dal vivo solo qui ma all'interno
dell'università con dei club sono gruppi
di ragazzi che si come noi si aggregano
trovano le loro regole e improvvisamente
iniziano a coltivare i loro interessi
bene
Abbiamo costruito la nostra strategia
abbiamo capito che dovevamo parlare fare
una comunicazione su tutti i canali e
quindi i canali di cui vi parlavo prima
perché le persone lì vogliono andare a
passare il loro tempo non a leggere
libri non a leggere i giornali purtroppo
ma passano tanto tempo a farsi
intrattenere dai Social bene allora su
questi canali bisogna avere una
comunicazione semplice bisogna andare a
ridurre i problemi complessi ai loro
fattori fondamentali
E questo ci ha permesso di costruire una
comunicazione imparziale parlando di
attualità tutti i giorni di economia si
va a toccare anche il mondo della
politica quindi vuol dire Dover
mantenere sempre una figura imparziale
al centro che faccia vedere diversi
punti di vista ma che dia la possibilità
di creare un proprio senso comune una
propria un proprio punto di vista
bene se facciamo tutto bene Qual è
l'effetto finale riusciamo a costruire
una comunicazione coinvolgente
Qualcosa che faccia sì che si possa
instaurare un rapporto ben preciso un
rapporto di fiducia
su questa fiducia c'è costruito il mondo
la fiducia nelle relazioni crea gli
scambi crea Le economie si cristallizza
in quello che chiamiamo soldi denaro la
moneta e che ci permette di portare
avanti le nostre vite e che noi
continuiamo a non conoscere
Allora vedete quando ho fatto ho
iniziato questo percorso non mi
aspettavo di arrivare qui oggi
mi aspettavo di arrivarci tra qualche
tempo quando avrei potuto dirvi il
mostro che abbiamo visto lo Abbiamo
sconfitto lo Abbiamo sconfitto insieme
Purtroppo non è così e c'è bisogno di
parlare di questi temi e quindi vi
invito a farlo anche voi a sentirvi
coinvolti a instaurare un rapporto di
fiducia e alzare la saracinesca anche
con i vostri amici anche con i vostri
familiari
perché
serve fare sempre qualcosa in più
bisogna continuare a raccontare le
storie ma basta ma non basta essere
bravi a raccontare le storie per essere
ascoltati Bisogna saper fare
appassionare il pubblico Grazie
[Applauso]